the people of patgo parten waited a long
time for this
to catch a glimpse of their long-lost
and much-loved idol the 12th century
statue of lakshmi narayan was worshipped
for centuries before it disappeared from
the town in
1984 we were sad when the deity we
worshiped disappeared were happy to get
it back
nearly 40 years later it is back where
it belongs the statue was briefly seen
at sotheby's auction house in new york
in the early 90s before vanishing again
it then reappeared at the dallas museum
of art in texas artist and researcher
joy lynn davis spotted it in an online
image search six years ago since then
she's been working with nepali heritage
activists and fbi agents to ensure its
return to nepal it feels like a bit of
like a bit of justice in the world and
also just a
a wonderful happiness to see the see it
returned and actually back in worship
again in the original temple it's it's
it's the dream
it's a dream come true for for many of
us
temple custodians conducted religious
rights before reinstating the statue in
its shrine we're in part of dharma
square a unesco world heritage site in
the past dozens of kathmandu valleys
venerated deities have disappeared from
here into private and museum collections
abroad
but what may be objects of art for many
have deep cultural and spiritual
significance for generations of nepalese
the 1980s and 90s saw the plunder of
bronze deities and stone sculptures from
kathmandu's valley region two important
books the gods are leaving the country
and stolen images of nepal have
painstakingly documented more than 200
missing artifacts the books raised
awareness about the thefts and
trafficking in cultural heritage
heritage activists say there is
increasing pressure on western
collectors and museums to return nepal's
stolen treasures
when they see how we worship and take
care of our deities i'm sure people will
be happy to return them when they
realize what they have is stolen they
must feel guilty while only a small
percentage of nepal's stolen idols have
found their way home activists welcome
this happy homecoming as the start of a
positive trend ramyath limbu al jazeera
kathmandu